welcome back to las vegas now this is
the fuel we need to keep us going this
weekend okay gonna go guys the sponsors
of this next segment is hosting a
community give back giving thanks and
filling tanks so let's welcome guy of
conoco and whitney of iheart media
welcome to the show
thank you for having us oh thank you i'm
so excited to tell everybody about this
because we're excited as we drive
through these streets we're looking at
five we're looking at six four it's just
gas prices are crazy they are so tell us
why you're doing this event and what we
can expect unfortunately with everything
that's going on right now covert
restrictions inflation
food on the rise clothing on the rise
gas on the rise everything on there
everything on the rise unemployment on
the rise we like to give back to our
community by giving back and maybe not
much but a little bit
a little bit goes a long way he loads a
little way so we do what we can okay so
what are you actually giving us so what
we're doing is we're selling uh from 12
to 1.99 a gallon tomorrow tomorrow from
12 to saturday correct dollar 9900
gallon we're also doing six dollars
express hand car washes
all day long that's going to be all the
events
porter sub will be there with us as well
to give away some free sandwiches we
also have free subs
for limited you know as long as they
last
don't pull up at 5pm
exactly
we teamed up with i heart radio a great
partner
i think we have we are broadcasting on
four different stations and also have a
live dj dj kilo on site spinning well
that brings me to you now just explain
the vibe and how you guys are really
making this a party for the community
we're bringing the party the
entertainment so we'll have all stations
out there i heart representing we've got
our dj kilo he'll be spinning live and
just you know having a good time so we'd
love to invite everyone down okay so how
can people get more information if they
want to give you guys a call throughout
the day absolutely so the event is
actually taking place at 70 east
centennial parkway in north las vegas
nevada it's vip car washing conical
phillips gas
on almost cross faces fifth in
centennial
um
northwest vegas let's get down pull up
tomorrow you guys 199 a gallon that's
correct oh my gosh whatever car you have
that is a blessing come on down bring
your family down have a good time get
your car washed
up
thank you guys so much thank you so much
for having us and thank you again to
conoco gasps for sponsoring that segment
their community give back event is
tomorrow saturday from 12 to 2 p.m on 70
east centennial parkway for more
information give this number a call
702-683-8008